when she said is absolutely true that's
Paul Wesley reacting to Nina Dobrev
claims they once despised each other
while filming the Vampire Diaries
Paul and I didn't get along at the
beginning of the show I respected Paul
Wesley I didn't like Paul and I realize
now that there's a fine line between
love and hate and we despise each other
so much that it read as love but it was
like burning this just like we really
just didn't get along at the first maybe
five months of shooting first of all
Nina's my really good friend now we talk
all the time and it's true when we first
started shooting the Vampire Diaries
we totally clashed it's just like it
just did we didn't creatively it just
wasn't in sync the fans would never have
known that but we like we're basically
driving each other insane and then after
a few seasons we developed this absolute
mutual love and I actually think that my
best friendships always come from like
this kind of like evolution and so now I
just adore her she adores me and and I
talk to her probably more than most of
the other cast members but but yeah what
and then Alyssa I texted yeah I'm like
what is this
am i keyed out and I actually was I
think she did the podcast on Candice
Candice Kings podcast or whatever I was
actually with Candice and she's like oh
my god they and so it was a little bit
blown out of proportion but but yeah
it's true we had them you know she was
just like oh my god I'm so sorry wait
why why did they you know but but know
is it's true it's true but our account
you know and I think the people the
reason people were surprised because you
know it was sort of like the the pillar
of the the love story I suppose in the
first few seasons or whatever and I
think people were like
you know what do you mean they didn't
get along